[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEGHAN MEHTA: We have had
so much fun showing you
I/O. But now, it's
time to hear from I/O.
Let's go do some meetups.
How many festivals have
you been to so far?
SPEAKER: How many festivals?
MEGHAN MEHTA: Google I/O.
SPEAKER: This is my second.
MEGHAN MEHTA: It's
your second Google I/O?
SPEAKER: It's my second.
SPEAKER: This is my first one.
SPEAKER: This is my fourth.
MEGHAN MEHTA: It's
your fourth one?
SPEAKER: Yeah, my
fourth as well.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Wow.
What about you guys?
SPEAKER: Fourth
one-- the fourth I/O?
MEGHAN MEHTA: Yeah.
SPEAKER: This is
your fourth I/O?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
SPEAKER: First one for me.
SPEAKER: First one for me too.
SPEAKER: I have probably
seven festivals.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Seven?
Oh my gosh.
You're a veteran.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MEGHAN MEHTA: What was your
favorite technology that Google
came out with this year?
SPEAKER: Flutter.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Assistant.
Everything about the Assistant.
The updates are fantastic.
MEGHAN MEHTA: What's your
guys's favorite thing
that you've seen so far?
SPEAKER: Definitely
the thing with Disney.
SPEAKER: Oh, the
thing now from Disney.
SPEAKER: Yeah, great king.
SPEAKER: What was the name of
the people that were dancing
on the ice cream down here?
MEGHAN MEHTA: The Fungineers.
SPEAKER: They were amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
They were so funny.
SPEAKER: With us, anything
with Google Photos as well.
SPEAKER: Yeah, for me,
it's the environment.
All the people or the
people just working
on something great
that's with technology.
I think that's amazing.
MEGHAN MEHTA: What is the
craziest thing you've ever
asked your Google Assistant?
SPEAKER: Am I hungry?
SPEAKER: Will I
ever find a husband?
MEGHAN MEHTA: I'm
just saying there's
a ton of men around here.
SPEAKER: It's true.
SPEAKER: So I have a
five-year-old niece.
And she loves
having conversations
with the voice and stuff.
It's just like, what's
your favorite color?
And do you want to go
to the moon with me?
MEGHAN MEHTA: Next I/O--
SPEAKER: Mm-hmm?
MEGHAN MEHTA: --if
Google could do anything,
what would you want
to see next year?
SPEAKER: OK.
"Smell-a-vision."
MEGHAN MEHTA: I love it.
I want smell-a-vision.
SPEAKER: So you can see
everything and let's
be able to smell it now.
SPEAKER: How about
the car that hovers?
MEGHAN MEHTA: I love it.
SPEAKER: Well, and
drives itself as well.
SPEAKER: Yeah, and
hovers at the same time.
SPEAKER: Self-driving hover car.
SPEAKER: I would like to see
more integration towards humans
and artificial
intelligence, so it's
not about artificial
intelligence only.
But I think the future that
Google is trying to build,
or should build,
is a combination
of artificial
intelligence with humans.
SPEAKER: Google Barber.
MEGHAN MEHTA: Google Barber?
What is that?
SPEAKER: So think of it, right?
Like, each time
I go to the salon
I want to [INAUDIBLE]
exactly which haircut I want.
So based on my
activities or my actions,
and my previous haircut
history, it could basically
tell me what exactly I want.
SPEAKER: If they can
do the Google Assistant
in Ampari, our local language.
If they could support Google in
Ampari, that would be awesome.
MEGHAN MEHTA: That
would be great.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MEGHAN MEHTA: What do you
want to see next year?
SPEAKER: AR dog
walking, fox to trot.
MEGHAN MEHTA: AR dog walking.
You heard it here first.
It's our next trend.
[MUSIC PLAYING]